thank you
I just want to make a little bit
expensive about the expansion of the
small set but there's many edges along
the outside
so I'm not going really to prove it but
just I would say what's the worst case
so
when you have the set
area of of nodes in
and uh
the Boolean hypercube
let's say that you have some size of
this set a and you want to put them in a
way that has as less edges going outside
that you can so the best that you can do
is to put it in a humming ball
that has
that has many as many as a point inside
a lot of them looks like
let's say that it's around zero
it has radius d
foreign
s all the subsets
and subset
on Thursday
so now how many edges going outside from
this ball
so every point that has
coming great less than the ones in it
all of its uh neighbors will be inside
the ball
so the only ones that contribute to the
others going outside are those that are
in the actually in the boundary of the
notes so those of size d
so we have
and choose the
of those and each one contribute
uh n minus D edges going outside
now if a is of the size of the ball
and the size of the size of the ball is
approximately
yes
okay
so now
actually a and the boundary of a is
approximately the same
foreign
over a
which is
exactly
the density of a
like this end just give us a
normalization of
of the size of a
okay so if you believe that this is the
best thing that you can do then to get
the lower bound
how many are just going outside
this is for the previous hour
[Music]
I want to say something else about the
professor which is
at some point
in between the other things
so
okay sorry if you remember
yes you remember it was not to put on
um that we consider the Fourier
characters
for Boolean function as the distribution
probabilities
and
we want to talk about
sparse functions and concentration and
we'll see why it's important
let's define what is a
for yes pass function
so we say that function Boolean function
is fast actually
it might be also functions to the r
um if the Fourier distribution is
supported on a small set of characters
it's actually if we use annotation of
how much then it's actually saying that
the spectrum of f
is bounded
um
foreign
[Music]
if it is close to four years pass
so here and if it's true to say that
just to add the Epsilon here
yeah okay so
we want no natural
okay never mind so we want to say that
the function is is concentrated we just
say it's consider it if it's close to
Fourier star signal to Norm so we talked
about that to normal right
um
so why we are interested in spous
functions and concentrated functions and
all of this so one thing that we know to
do with spouse functions
um is to learn them
in order to do it for long
to actually win
they show how to learn sparse and
concentrate function
um
and
quite very simply I'm not sure what year
it was I don't know why I didn't write
it here we know also how to learn
agnostically uh concentrate functions
so this is important
uh
no we just need this password to be in
the boot camp
[Music]
aign
bye
okay
um okay so why not sort of concentration
of
distribution is of descriptions is a
Shannon entropy
so what is the Shannon entropy I will
have a definition soon and
you can think if if you're not familiar
with this you can think about it as a
log of the size of the support
put it here
if someone doesn't feel comfortable with
the Shannon answer key then
out entropy
play log
IC
the formal definition is
so usually we don't write it with
expectation maybe it was because I
didn't have enough
space in this slide
so the channel entropy
any distribution and specifically the
distribution the Fourier distribution is
a summation over
all the probabilities
if the probability log 1 over
and
I think we know that the Shannon entropy
is small
then we we very easily can say that it's
also concentrated just use a very simple
Markov inequality
um
to sure that
uh the large ones in order to be very
small there it's become with very small
probability
so we have
actually the probability to be smaller
this is exactly the L2 Norm difference
so we can just remove all the small ones
now we have that most of the rate is
concentrated on just exponentially in
the enthalpy in any characters
so again what this means that if the
function has lotion on entropy then we
can learn it
that's the opposite is true if we have a
concentrated function we know that we
have only few large Fourier coefficient
does it mean that Shannon entropy is
small
so the answer is no it might be that we
have a very small
weight that spread on too many
characters
oh yeah
so if we prove something about entropy
it will imply concentration but not the
opposite
uh but there is another notion of of
entropy
there is a mean entropy which is let us
Define it
I mean entropy is exactly what you
should think it is
instead of taking the summation or that
expectation just the minimum over
one over
okay
and it also use useful to think about it
like
[Music]
right at the maximum foreign
entropy it implies
no meaning entropy
because if we have a small set of
characters that has that are heavies and
at least one of them is heavy
definition of the video
we're saying that at least one one of
them is heavy it means exactly that the
minimum log is
small
so there is a famous conjecture in
the field of analysis of Boolean
functions the quality Fourier entropy
influence conjection
um
let's say that there exists
for every let's keep there's this for
every function Boolean function we can
bound we want to bound the
Channel entropy by the total influence
so the meaning of it is
that if the total influence is small
then we want to say that the function is
concentrated
but I should be interested in this
um
or if it's concentrated then we have
learning we have sharp threshold
phenomena and uh
okay
um
we didn't success to prove it many years
then Brandon Donald and actually others
came up with some relaxation and said
okay if we don't know to bound the
entropy maybe we do not to bound mean
entropy which is always smaller than 10
rupee
um so this is another version
and
here's why about the Fourier entropy so
if this tour will have also agnostically
learning for dnf and
this actually
non-trivial results for
small influences that for influence that
are not very small but uh
of order of login
and
so what we will see today is a slightly
weaker version of this
we'll get for it to it
um
because it's important to know what we
know
so we know that for your entropy
influence conductor for some specific
classes
um
or are not elaborate water classes are
but someone know them then it's good to
know that we know the FBI product so we
have symmetrics functions read one's
formulas
in our threshold functions
the other I'm not sure it's not
interesting now
there is something interesting that I
want to show
um
so the foreign
because it's uh weaker we have other
classes and
generally we know that the the mean
entropy is at most the influence squared
so let's see where we know this from
[Music]
um
so I want to show you the fried good
point that theorem which is very
important basically om
we don't want to tell them it's kind of
a generalization of the KKL
you are here again the KKL
we have
Boolean function
it's balanced
meaning that the expectation of f is
zero
and take care there exists some I that
the inference I of f
aced
so what I can show is that there exists
some variable at least one variable that
has large inference part three good
trade
all the
let's take all the influence the
variables that has large influence
and if we look at the function that
depends only on them
it will be close to the original
function
exist
G
function G
onza so Fanta meaning that it ends
only
variables
except J
uh for J which is not too large
is exponentially
in the total influence
so
that's that f and g
Flows In well to know
[Music]
something about the proof idea of this
where the statement is clear
thank you
we Define J is the set of the
variables of the that will be in the
Honda
because that the influence
it's large
constant
um
[Music]
then we can take just the
um
the characters the part of f the
characters of F that contained in J
and Cho
entire weight on
characters that are not contained in j
is at most Epsilon
so we can just remove them
when we just remove them we might end up
with function which is not necessarily
Boolean but this is easy to fix
network is the best now
um
so the big difference between the
calculate what is the the cake outside
at least one variable and fruit would
say let's take the variable that
promised by KKL let's take another one
foreign and all of them and this is
enough for us so you can say that you
can see that we have at most two
exponentially many in the influence
variables that has a large influence
so now how can we see the amino entropy
from here
and
there is another thing that I need for
this
and
this button Yeah you mentioned it's it's
easy to fix that our the function when
you remove a certain number of Forex
positions it's easy to fix it and make
it Boolean yeah how do you do this you
can just take the sign oh sure
um should pay attention it's not always
works because you need this uh
they seems to to preserve the what what
you want from the function the
properties so here it just depends on a
few variables if you set the sign it
still depends on the same amount of
variables but if you want to preserve
the degree for example it might be not
true
Okay so
the total influence they say this is the
expected degree
from the Fourier distribution
so now I want to play
every s
is close
law degree function
degree
it's not an influence over Epsilon
stabilization we need this
it's proof in order to show the free
platform three good domain entropy
um
just take the tail of s
and remove it
we get a loading function let's show
that this function is closed
G
um
thank you
F minus J equal to none
there's a
distance between them and take the on
your coefficients
so it's all the large on your
coefficients
it breaks on love foreign
Epsilon
of that
spoken inference is exactly the
expectation of s we use marker to say
this is at most FC
so now
um
let us prove that the entropy is at most
uh inference Square
so from the proof of the of frequent we
know that
um
the summation overall
characters that
are in j
he has at least one minus Epsilon
and if we remove from here the
characters that are larger than the
total influence over Epsilon
then we only lost another epilometer
and how many characters we have here
we need to choose uh
subsets of J of size at most
um
influence and of them are almost J so
this is at most
number of characters
such that as
a closed influence f
acilar
this is at most
J to the influence of our Epsilon which
is at most
um two to influence Square
so now we have
that many characters that all together
has
all the the right so at least one of
them have two to minus the increment
Square weight which is exactly the mean
entropy bounded by the influence Square
okay questions
we want to know better than that but
that is that this is I guess quite easy
um
yeah so I take all the answers that
contained in J the Fontan
with small size at most the influence
over Epsilon foreign
Epsilon squared in the exponent for the
final band
[Music]
maybe Square
um
okay so the best thing that we know
right and the mean entropy is not only
bounded by the influence square but it's
in we want influence but we know to
bound it by inference Lobby in France
you know also about the channel
foreign
why do we care about lower degree uh
functions and
it's very useful to say that the
function is close to if it has small
total influence and close to our degree
because we have the hyperconductivity
which
it's very useful with improving things
in Boolean functions
so what it said that
for every function which exactly the
exact degree is at most D I mean that it
has no weight above the degree the
the lp Norm of 4 the L phonon is at most
is at most time constant depends on D
Norms but let me Define it again or in
the first time
foreign
and
I'm not going to say anything about this
I just want to use it as it is and
hopefully
it would have more sense about it till
the end of this week
maybe tomorrow morning and
okay but let us uh remember it
so
you know that uh
internal use
and turn on
this is the height
and this is true for every function to
the r okay it's not only for Boolean
functions but actually for
minus one one functions I think it
doesn't give us anything
maybe four zero one
Okay so
how should we bound the entropy
sure the main goal now is to bound the
the entropy of the Fourier distribution
and all the proof is going
to use correlation between functions
um
you can do it slowly and
let's see I hope that we can prove the
KKL and threadwood at least
this is a general
population bound
so
we have
the first function f is Boolean the
second function going to R but we know
about it that it's boundary degree
and we have some
promise about the influences of f you
know that all the influences are small
um and then
what we want to prove is that the
correlation between f and g
and which
I guess is
you find at some point
information between f and g is just an
expectation
over all the values at X
and similarly to the person valve and
this is plential or something like this
we can just
take all the Fourier coefficients
let's see
um do you want to put elaborate this
step or okay
foreign
between f and g is just something let's
uh I think that we can do without
thinking about it too much
um okay let's prove this it's going to
be one line using diaper conductivity
it might not make any sense but just use
some
uh
whoops
so
if we think about the
the functions the f and g the the
correlation as the summation of the
characters
um
we can see that the every character
we will we might allow ourselves to uh
to count characters more than one time
if we assume that all the signs are the
same so all of them are positive
um so now we we can just say this is at
most if we take the derivatives so the
derivatives just reminds
um
it's just all the characters that
contains I for every eye
so now the only thing that we change
from here to here is to count every
character as many times as it's uh the
size
so it only can be large
and
for such correlations we can use helders
inequality so we take a very specific
numbers for Elder and bound the
correlation with
the fourth third norm and fourth Norm so
why we choose these numbers
so
we have the hyperconductivity that works
for every function not only booleans
therefore we want the fourth Norm
because we know to bound it
we put the first Normand J
which is general and and then we get the
fourth third
Norm on the
on the derivative of f
so now using diaper constructivity react
here a factor of exponentially in D
but we know that D is a degree that g is
abundance of this degree
and for the other one this is very
useful to know that
this is a derivative so we say that it
takes values minus one zero and one
and when we take
norms
the minus one one
actually goes together they have the
same value the same contribution
and all the Norms actually equal
up to
situation like it's really easy to go
from now one on to another Norm
just apply this okay so this was a short
proof maybe not very interesting for now
but let's see that this correlation
actually implies the KKL
sorry if we take
um
let's assume the tough is balanced and
we choose D to be twice the total
inference or we think about Epsilon half
um and then take G to B the lower degree
part of f all the
characters that are at most d
let Delta to be the maximal influence
so now just apply
this correlation on
F and its law degree part
we get that this is at most the maximal
influence exponentially in D which is
the influence the total influence now
and another influence which is not a lot
when we have exponentially in the
influence
um
and another thing that we have that we
have to note here once we took D to B
twice a total influence we lost only at
most half of the
of the weight exactly the same as we did
before
so we know that the correlation between
F and its nor degree part which is
exactly
um
the the weight of the Fourier
coefficient up to the in price inference
exactly staff at least constant
so from here we can direct that the
maximal influence Delta is at least
exponentially in the total influence
I guess this one's shorter than what we
had in the last the previous hour
and hopefully tomorrow you will have
more sense about it
um
so now the question is can we do better
correlations
and
this needs a bit work to make it better
so if you if you're not here we just
assume that all the influences are small
so now we can think about that we have
some small influences some larger
influences but
I was reassured in the proof of the free
book theorem we can't have too many
large influences
so we can just take them separately
you can see now that we have another
correlation inequality between again a
Boolean function and the lower degree
function
um
well now Delta is for every Delta we
just have two parts of the of the bound
one of them will be similar to what we
had previously with all the influencers
that Atmos Delta and the other one just
said okay we don't have too many that
has more than Delta and they contribute
at most something trivial
this is actually the proof let's skip it
and
see what we can implies from this
or if again we take
D to be twice a total influence and uh
Delta which is to be
exponentially small in the influence
and again G to be at the lower degree
path
then
putting all of this here in the
correlation bound we get that we have at
least one Fourier coefficient which is
large
larger than
exponentially in the total inference
Square which give us exactly what we
know from free good theorem that the
mean entropy is at most the total
insurance Square
any questions about it
foreign
so now
uh this question is can we do better we
want to get to the influence Times log
the influence
and
you see what we do is to apply the
hyperconductivity which we need law
degree so maybe we can do reduce the
degree before we apply the hyper
constructivity
and that way or we already know to do we
just do random restrictions right
we already know to do random
restrictions
let's see what we have here at the end
so if we start with
some d
with degree D and we take
um
the random restrictions with v over d
for some V which is much smaller
option enough uh
so we want to reduce the degree D to
degree V so we take the random
restriction to be V over D we expect the
characters
uh to the Fourier rate from the degree D
now to go to the degree Most B
what we can get
so now if if we do the restriction for
both f and g
this is actually the Restriction J is
implicit here
will be hard to do it without the
operating more
so the idea is that one once we do the
Restriction we have low degree can now
apply the uh
the hyperconductivity with the lower
degree we get now exponentially in V
here
and we always have the other part so we
can repeatedly do this process again and
again
um we take how many large parts we have
we apply diaper constructivity apply a
random restriction and if we do it
enough times we finally get to the log
somehow we can't do better than that
um
so this is actually we applied the
previous uh inequality
the first equality
okay yeah so actually this is
interesting so you can think about it
that you take actually when you do
random restriction you first choose the
what variables are going to set to be
alive so here we are after this we do
only expectation over Z which is
actually what uh part of the hypercube
we chose
you can actually actually get that
partition of the hypercube
for some Sub sub cubes when each Z just
choose a different hypercube and they
have no intersection
so when you do expectation over all the
function or over just the sub cubes
and then expected the overall of them
just linearity of expectation you get
the same yeah this is nice of
observation from here maybe the most
useful one say yes
if you just want to improve that power
too to say to minus Epsilon
is it enough to do one round of this
instead of recursively if I if I so what
you get from fruit cut is you get this
mini entropy is at most
c times I squared right yeah
if you just want to improve that too to
say two minus Epsilon
you have to do this recursion like
repeatedly do I'm not sure
do refer exactly let's take it offline
um
skip this
[Music]
but
yeah it's in purpose
um okay so here the main thing that I
want to say about uh oh this is that you
uh you that we can do the such
correlations
very general bounds and correlations
that we think about uh just one function
is boundary degree and the other
function is Boolean and and the idea of
once we have this uh boundary degree we
do random restrictions we lower the
degree we can do it again and again
until we have the the result that that
we want
um another thing that I want to show
and I hope that I can draw
um
is about concentration
oops
all right so actually the idea about the
concentration is to show that we have uh
most of the weight uh on very few number
of uh Fourier coefficients
and another notion of this is the L1
Norm of the Fourier coefficients
so let's say that we have
Malaysian
s let's say that we know
how to bound the
the summation of the Fourier coefficient
then one on with some l
um
I can give an example
Russian
so we just moved to something else
another notion of concentration okay
okay
just turn the radar you can do
about decision trees
off
for example
so okay what is a decision tree
we have
a tree that we can query one variable
which is let's say some x i and if it is
zero we were here if it's one we were
here and then we can query another
variables
who are there and on the end on the
leaves we have values
let's say each Leaf is either zero or
one
so this is a way to compute a function
if a function is computable by a small
decision tree
um then we can know some things about
this function for example we can bound
the L1
Norm of the Fourier coefficients so if
we have uh in the decision tree at most
L nodes
we can show that the uh the L1 is at
most l
the way to do it is quite easy we do it
induct inductively so every leaf can
contribute at most one
of course this is only one
um this is constant function or you can
grow above this is just a dictatorship
and when you we combine two functions we
can see that it can combine at most the
amount
of of both the parts
so for example this is going to be
interesting for decision trees
um
online
bounded
foreign
how can we see it so let's uh see how
many Fourier coefficients larger than
new we can have
let us be such that f s
in at least mu or some new
how many of this we can have
so here it's it's useful to
to look at the Fourier coefficient
Square
B sequence one
and
this is at most
number of this that we have here times
mu Square
and this is at most one over mu Square
so whenever we want just to say that we
have atmosphere it's at most uh
coefficients that are louder than new we
have at least one over mu square but
what is the reasonable meal to take here
so we need to show that all the others
that are outside new
um
contribute not too much
if it takes a summation overall s such
that for year coefficient
is at most mule
well
now we can take the we know something
about the L1 so let's take the maximal
inside
the L1
so the maximal we know is at most new
when that one is L so we have at most M
over L if we want this to be at most
Epsilon
we just choose new
foreign
Epsilon over l
and then we get here
L over Epsilon
so this is another way to show
concentration
um
I'm not sure
again
oh I mean it's just pretty technical I
was just wondering yeah I think it's
yeah I guess you have to get proof here
thank you